I've been trying to make this argument
more recently
um it might write an essay on it is you
know people talk about the great filter
right and which is again this like
Doomsday thing that you know people want
to say there's no aliens out there
because something terrible happened to
them
um and it matters whether that's in our
in our past or our future as to the
longevity of our species presumably
which is why people find it interesting
but I think it's not it's not a physical
filter it's not like things go extinct I
think it's literally we don't have the
technology to see them
um and you can see that with microscopes
I mean we didn't know there were
microbes on this table for our tables
for thousands of years or telescopes
like there's so much of the universe we
can't see and then basically what we
have done as a species is Outsource our
physical perceptions to Technology
Building microscopes based on our eyes
um you know and building size monitors
based on our sense of feelings like feel
earthquakes and things and AI is
basically we're trying to Outsource
what's actually happening in our
thinking apparatus into machines now
into technological devices and maybe
that's the key technology that's going
to allow us to see things like
and see the universe in a totally
different way but you kind of mentioned
the great filter do you think there's a
way through technology to stop being
able to see stuff so can you take stuff
backwards I think so yeah did you imply
that with a great so like well no I mean
I think there's a great perceptual
filter in the sense that a a
example of Life evolving on a planet
over billions of years has to acquire a
certain amount of knowledge and
Technology to actually recognize the
phenomena that it is well that's the
sense I have is uh I mean you talk with
physicists engineers in general there's
this kind of idea that we have most of
the tools already to hear the signal but
to me it feels like we don't have any of
the tools yeah I agree that's that's the
biggest like to hear we don't have the
tools to really hear to see yeah
aliens everywhere we just don't have the
exactly the um yeah I mean well
oh that's I mean I got this in part
actually because you were like you know
last time I was here he's like look at
the carpet you know could it like if you
had an Alien Detector with carpet be
aliens I mean I think we really don't
I I would be but aliens would
nevertheless have a high assembly index
or produce things of high assembly yeah
yeah and those things of a high assembly
index
uh you have to have a detector that can
recognize High assembly index in all its
forms yeah yes that's it that's it take
data construct assembly space yeah this
patterns basically so one way to think
about high assembly index is interesting
patterns uh of basic ingredients I can
give you an example because I mean in
molecules we've been talking about in
objects but we're also trying to do it
in spatial trajectories like imagine
you're just
um like I I always get bothered by the
fact that like when you look at birds
flocking you can describe that with like
a simple boys model or like you know
people use spin glass to describe animal
behavior and those are like really
simple physics models yet you're looking
at a system that you know has agency and
there's intelligence in those birds and
I and basically like you can't help but
think there must be some statistical
signatures of the fact that they're
those are that's a group of Agents
versus you know like I don't know you
know the physics example maybe like I
don't know brownie emotion or something
um and so what we're trying to do is
actually apply assembly to trajectory
data to try to say there's a minimal
amount of causal history to build up
certain trajectories for observed agents
that's like an agency detector for
Behavior do you think it's possible to
do some like like Boyds or uh those
kinds of things like artificial like
cellular automata play with those ideas
with assembly
um well assembly Theory have you found
any useful really simple mathematical
um like simulation tools that allow you
to play with these Concepts so like one
of course you're doing Mass Spec in this
physical space with with chemistry but
it just seems about me computer science
person maybe it seems easier to just I
agree with you and sexier in terms of uh
tweeting visual information on uh
Twitter or Instagram more importantly
um to play like here's an organism of a
low assembly index and here's an
organism of a high assembly index and
let's watch them create more and more
memories uh and more and more complex
objects and so like in mathematically
you get to observe what that looks like
to build up an intuition what assembly
index is like we are building a toolkit
right now so I think it's a really good
idea but what we've got to do is I'm
kind of still obsessed with the
infrastructure required and one of the
reasons why I was pushing on information
and Mathematics when human beings when
human being we take a lot of the
infrastructure for granted and and I
think we have to strip that back a bit
for going forward but you're absolutely
right I would agree that I think the the
fact that we exist in the universe is
like I can see there are lots of people
can disagree with the statement but I
don't think I don't think Sarah will but
I don't know the fact that objects exist
I don't think anyone on Earth can just
will disagree
that objects can Exist Elsewhere right
but they all disagree that life can
Exist Elsewhere but what perhaps I'm
trying to say is that the the the
acquisition the universe's ability to
acquire memory
is the very first step for building life
and that must be that's so easy to
happen so therefore alien life is
everywhere because all alien life is is
uh those memories being compressed and
minimalized and the alien equivalent of
the cell working
so I think that we will build new
technologies to find aliens
um but we do not we need to understand
what we are first and and how we go
through from physics to chemistry to
biology
the most interesting thing as you're
saying these two organisms different
assemblies is when you get into biology
biology gets more and more weird more
and more contingent where physics is pro
chemistry is less weird because the
rules of chemistry are small in the
rules of biology and then going away to
physics where you have a very
nicely tangible number of ways of
arranging things and I think the 70
Theory just helps you appreciate that
and so once we get there my dream is
that we are just going to be able to
suddenly our I mean I'm I mean I've
maybe just being really arrogant here
I'm not mean to be arrogant it's just
again I've just got this hammer called
assembly and everything's a nail but I
think that once we crack it we'll be
able to use assembly Theory plus
telescopes to find aliens